dear fellow scholars this is two minute
papers with károly zsolnai-fehér
in earlier episodes we've seen plenty of
video footage about hair simulations and
rendering and today we are going to look
at a cool new technique that produces
self shadowing effects for hair and fur
in this image pair you can see this
drastic difference that shows how
prominent this effect is in the visual
appearance of hair just look at that
beautiful but computing such a thing is
extremely costly since we have a dance
piece of geometry for instance hundreds
of thousands of hair strands we have to
know how each one occludes the other
ones
this will take hopelessly long to
compute to even get a program that
executes in a reasonable amount of time
we clearly need to simplify the problem
further an earlier technique takes a few
planes that cut the hair volume into
layers these planes are typically
regularly spaced outwards from the light
sources and it is much easier to work
with a handful of these volume segments
than with the full geometry the more
planes we use the more layers we obtain
and the higher quality results we can
expect however even if we can do this in
real time we will produce and realistic
images when using around sixteen layers
well of course we should then crank up
the number of layers some more if we do
that for instance by now using 128
layers we can expect better quality
results but we'll be able to process an
image only twice a second which is far
from competitive and even then the final
results still contain layering artifacts
and are not very close to the ground
truth there has to be a better way to do
this and with this new technique called
deep opacity maps these layers are
chosen more widely and this way we can
achieve higher quality results with
using only three layers and it runs
easily in real time it is also more
memory efficient than previous
techniques the key idea is that if we
look at the hair from the light sources
point of view we can record how far away
different parts of the geometry are from
the light source then we can create the
new layers further and further away
according to this shape this way the
layers are not planar anymore they adapt
to the scene that we have at hand and
contain significantly more useful
occlusion information as you can see
this new technique blows all previous
methods away and is incredibly simple
I have found an implementation from
Philip write out the link to this is
available in the video description if
you have found more let me know and I
will include your findings in the video
description for the fellow tinker's out
there the paper is ample in comparisons
make sure to have a look at that too and
sometimes I get some messages saying
Catterick why do you bother covering
papers from so many years ago it doesn't
make any sense and here you can see that
part of the excitement of two minute
papers is that the next episode can be
about absolutely anything the series has
been mostly focusing on computer
graphics and machine learning papers but
don't forget that we also have an
episode on whether we are living in a
simulation or the dunning-kruger effect
and so much more I'll put a link to both
of them in the video description for
your enjoyment the other reason for
covering older papers is that a lot of
people don't know about them and if we
can help just a tiny bit to make sure
these incredible works see more
widespread adoption we've done our job
well thanks for watching and for your
generous support and I'll see you next
time
[Music]